[Music]  Emme peas vote on a draft law reducing  the risks for workers to be exposed to  carcinogens especially linked to diesel  engines exhausts violence against  journalists economic pressures and how  the industry is dealing with fake news  are on the agenda of the civil liberties  committee MEP who criticized the lack of  transparency of the appointment of the  European Commission Secretary General  Martin cell Meyer they will hold a  public hearing on the issue from April  2018 every new car in Europe will have  to be equipped with the equal device it  automatically sends important data in  case of an accident to rescue services  as a 1st of April a new regulation  enables travelers in the EU to access  their online subscriptions to films  video games or music services as if they  are at home